while big tech companies have been
performing well there seems to be a new
movement within the tech industry that's
also thriving the anti-big tech tech
industry most of these companies don't
create anything groundbreaking or
revolutionary their value proposition
lies in what they don't do DuckDuckGo
doesn't collect your browsing data
signal doesn't spy on your personal
conversations just as fast as these apps
Rose in popularity they're also crashing
in popularity they want to offer the
best parts of Google and Facebook
without paying the price and that's
simply impossible because nothing comes
for free if users aren't paying with
money they have to pay with their
attention by watching ads and by
sacrificing their privacy that's how
businesses work they offer a service or
product for a price and if customers
aren't paying the business is simply not
viable